[Musik]
es gibt wirklich nachbarn die haben sich
eingedeckt für die nächsten wochen oder
ja auch ältere leute oder leute die sich
nicht wirklich darüber informieren
können die haben auch angst
großveranstaltungen zu besuchen nur dass
die leute alle verrückt sind oder um
hier irgendwelche dinge zu kaufen die
immer da sind
ich weiß mir mein handy ganz regelmäßig
ich esse vitamine gefiel landluft und
hoffe dass es an mir vorbeigeht
wie beeinflusst das corona virus unseren
alltag das waren stimmen aus berlin und
damit herzlich willkommen zum zdf
spezial jeden tag neue fälle die immer
schneller steigende zahl von corona
infektionen in deutschland war zu
erwarten
und der höhepunkt ist noch nicht
erreicht sagt bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen
aber es gibt auch diese meldungen immer
mehr menschen sind mittlerweile schon
wieder gesund und experten sind
optimistisch das ist schon ein paar
wochen medikamente zur behandlung des
corona virus geben könnte
über die aktuelle lage berichtet holger
müller in koblenz simulieren sie den
corona ernstfall die sanitäter floriani
bald und dirk sowohl schlüpfen in ihre
schutzkleidung so würden sie im
ernstfall ausrücken um einen möglichen
infizierten abzuholen
ein solcher ernstfall ist nur noch eine
frage der zeit denn die zahl der
infektionen nimmt täglich zu
und das wird auch selbstverständlich in
den nächsten tagen und wochen so
weitergehen
wann die den höhepunkt erreicht ist das
können wir nicht sagen
das robert-koch-institut hat südtirol
mittlerweile zum risikogebiet erklärt
auch in anderen teilen italiens kommt
das öffentliche leben weitgehend zum
erliegen in rom bleibt der sonst übliche
touristenansturm aus manche touristen
sehen es sogar positiv keine schlangen
nicht einmal vor den restaurants
mediziner können das virus jedoch nicht
auf die leichte schulter nehmen wieder
bei sich selbst noch bei ihren patienten
in der kreisklinik groß gerau gibt es
beispielsweise jetzt eine art corona
drei verdachtsfälle werden direkt auf
dem klinik parkplatz behandelt kommen
darf aber nur wer vom gesundheitsamt
dazu aufgefordert wird das prozedere hat
entscheidende vorteile
schnell unkompliziert pragmatisch sicher
aber auch an mögliche infizierte ohne
auto ist gedacht sie können sie hier
aufnehmen lassen um dann isoliert zu
werden denn manche kommen einfach
unangemeldet patient in der praxis
reinkommt hinterher als positiv getestet
wird schon alle anderen kontakt mit dem
hat im prinzip müssen sind die ganze
praxis oder klinik betrieb aus alten ein
szenario dem sie auch in koblenz
vorbeugen wollen wer von profis zu hause
abgeholt wird gefährdet schließlich
niemanden mehr
gründliche desinfektion vorausgesetzt
ihren halten sich halt sehr lange auf
oberflächen ja können vier bis neun tage
auch infektions bleiben sich auf
oberflächen halten und deswegen muss man
die wirklich gründlich abwaschen
aber egal wie gründlich solche
reinigungen ausfallen eines steht fest
wir alle müssen verstehen dass wir
dieses virus nicht aufhalten können dass
es sich ausbreitet sondern dass das
virus eben verlangsamt werden muss wir
müssen alles daran setzen dass wir den
verbreitung des virus verlangsamt
eine solche verlangsamung könnte man
beispielsweise mit bundesweiten corona
ferien erreichen möglicherweise gibt es
aber bereits eine lösung und zwar von
hier dem deutschen primatenzentrum in
göttingen untersuchungen legen nahe dass
ein bereits in japan zugelassenes
medikament eine infektion mit dem corona
virus verhindern könnte weitere studien
soll nun klarheit bringen ein
hoffnungsschimmer immerhin und das
wollen wir weiter vertiefen mit der
virologe professor melanie brinkmann vom
helmholtz zentrum für
infektionsforschung in braunschweig
frau professor brinkmann viele menschen
haben jetzt angst sich anzustecken wie
überträgt sich das wie russland genau
nur durch tröpfcheninfektion
ja das ist der wahrscheinlichste und
häufigste übertragungsweg die
tröpfcheninfektion das heißt wenn wir
miteinander sprechen und uns dabei nahe
sind
die tröpfchen lieber dabei entstehen
beim beim sprechen und auch beim husten
die können dann das gegenüber infizieren
aber es kann natürlich auch sein dass
menschen in die hand husten und dann
eine türklinke anfassen und dann kommt
es darauf an wann die nächste person
dann diese türklinke berührt und kann
sich dann auch theoretisch anstecken
aber nur wenn sie selber sich dann auch
ins gesicht fasst
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen sagt ja
jetzt der höhepunkt der epidemie ist
noch nicht erreicht was kommt denn da
noch auf uns zu da stimme ich ihm zu wir
werden weitere fälle haben in
deutschland das das wird so sein so leid
mir das tut das so zu sagen aber darauf
müssen wir uns vorbereiten und es ist
einfach so dieses virus wird sich seinen
weg suchen denn es hat hier
es trifft auf menschen die keinen schutz
gegen dieses virus haben und es hat
relativ freie bahn und was wir tun
können ist diese verbreitung so weit wie
es geht zu verlangsamen das ist jetzt
ganz ganz wichtig werden ja immer wieder
unterschiedliche sterberaten genannt das
verunsichert auch wie kommt es dazu
das kommt dazu davon dass man erst
einmal von der datenlage ausgeht die man
zur verfügung hat und die meisten daten
kommen bislang noch aus china und da ist
es schwierig denn man hat nicht die
komplette datenlage man weiß ja nicht
wie viele menschen sind insgesamt
infiziert worden
ich sehe ja nur die menschen die krank
werden was man dafür also bräuchte um
wirklich zuverlässige zahlen zu bekommen
sind tests die sagen welche person hat
die infektion schon durchgemacht und
diese tests werden gerade entwickelt das
sind sogenannte antikörper test wo ich
dann sehen kann die person ist nicht
mehr krank die infektionen liegt schon
ein wenig zurück aber diese person hatte
tatsächlich mal das virus und wenn man
diese daten hat dann kann man auch
irgendwann mal von einer wirklich guten
zahlen sprechen im moment sind es
vielen dank frau professor brinkmann für
das gespräch ja gerne mit einem
einfachen schnupfen zum arzt oder sogar
in die notaufnahme
weil menschen befürchten sich mit dem
corona virus infiziert zu haben kommt
das aktuell durchaus mal vor und die
wartezimmer sind sowieso schon voll
doch arztpraxen und krankenhäuser haben
noch ein ganz anderes problem ihnen
fehlt schutzkleidung die bundesregierung
hat deshalb ein exportverbot für
atemschutzmasken und andere
schutzausrüstung verhängt wie der alltag
in arztpraxen gerade aussieht zeigen
anna fein und stefan hanf morgens um
acht ist einiges los in dieser
hausarztpraxis in ingelheim am rhein
es ist ein kommen und gehen und alle
wollen zum dock für ihn ist das ein
problem frank hofbauer facharzt für
allgemeinmedizin
denn bei erkältungssymptomen derzeit
eine korrekte diagnose zu stellen ist
nicht so einfach das kann ich ganz
normale grippe so ein colour zum
beispiel corona virus sein und aktuell
haben wir hier das ist kein fake nun
aktuellen fall im wartezimmer der fürs
wartezimmer gegangen ist und mit dem
verdacht auf cholera eigentlich hätte
der patient vorher anrufen müssen hat er
aber nicht und die behandlung ist auch
deshalb keinesfalls routine
die patienten müssen wir das beim
gesundheitsamt anmelden und wir können
hier heute nicht diagnostizieren weil
wir keine abstriche haben wir haben auch
das entsprechende material nicht so das
bild alles genau das ist das größte
problem nicht nur die diagnose tests
fehlen auch die schutzkleidung also
mundschutz handschuhe kittel wird
langsam knapp
wir haben momentan noch guest vorräte
aber die sind im grunde genommen
aufgebraucht und der großhandel versucht
jedenfalls heute was zu besorgen
versprechen kann man da nicht eine halbe
stunde später rettungsdienst ist da
patient 34 jahre alt meint deshalb cola
virus haben könnte und hatte kontakt auf
dem bahnhof deshalb 40 grad fieber seit
mehreren tagen wo ist denn
gliederschmerzen oder auch der junge
mann wird ins krankenhaus gebracht der
behandlungsraum desinfiziert und solange
der korona verdacht nicht bestätigt ist
hat der fall für die praxis und die
anderen patienten keine folgen
wir müssen uns natürlich schützen das
ist ja klar und wir müssen die patienten
schützen
frage sollte man die praxis dann zu
machen wenn überhaupt kein schutz
bestehe besteht diese frage muss vorerst
offen bleiben am nächsten tag immerhin
ist klar der junge patient leidet an
influenza und nicht am neuartigen corona
virus da sind also die herausforderungen
vor denen arztpraxen geradestehen
doch auch an anderer stelle macht sich
das corona virus bemerkbar und sorgt für
ungewöhnliche bilder zum beispiel vom
biathlon-weltcup vormenschen leeren
rängen oder vom fußball in italien ohne
fangesang aber auch über
großveranstaltungen wie messen wird
diskutiert und immer mehr davon werden
auch in deutschland abgesagt
die fahnen der internationalen
tourismusbörse in berlin wehen aber die
große reisemesse die vorgestern beginnen
sollte ist komplett abgesagt ein
weiterer schwerer schlag für die
reisebranche
die besonders von dem weltweit
grassierenden corona virus betroffen ist
kann ich umbuchen kann nicht stornieren
kann ich von meiner reise zurücktreten
das sind die ganz konkreten
fragestellungen die können wir nicht
einheitlich beantworten auch in leipzig
flattern die fahnen in diesem märz nicht
für die besucher der buchmesse
die veranstaltung ist wegen des corona
virus abgesagt die große industriemesse
in hannover ist erstmal von april auf
juli verlegt worden und die austragung
des fußball länderspiels deutschland
gegen italien ende märz in nürnberg ist
momentan unsicher wenn die entscheidung
heute zu treffen wäre würde die
stadtverwaltung wegen der vielen
besucher aus italien eine achse
empfehlen bei mir im studio begrüße ich
jetzt dr wolfgang kohnen
stellvertretender leiter der abteilung
hygiene und infektionsprävention an der
uniklinik mainz schön dass ihr alle da
sind
guten tag herr dr kronen jetzt wurden ja
schon viele großveranstaltungen in
deutschland abgesagt wir haben es gerade
gehört kann das tatsächlich helfen die
verbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen
das mit sicherheit ein gutes mittel um
eine verbreitung zu verlangsamen sie
müssen bedenken wenn ich bei einer
großveranstaltung bin habe ich in
kontakt mit anderen menschen das heißt
der übertragungsweg für das virus
analyse einfach das zweite große problem
was wir haben ist unsere strategie ist
zurzeit die infizierten zu erkennen zu
isolieren und entsprechende gene
maßnahmen zu machen wenn sie bei einer
großveranstaltung sind wissen sie am
ende nicht wenn es zu der tat kam wer
jetzt infiziert wurde wir finden diese
leute die ich nie werden dann unerkannt
weiter in der bevölkerung sich bewegen
warum dann kein generelles
veranstaltungs verbot wie es zum
beispiel in anderen ländern schon da ist
oder auch ein einreiseverbot oder auch
schulschließungen wie zb in italien bau
machen wir das nicht also ich beziehe
mich jetzt mal auf die großveranstaltung
also die regeln sind natürlich
unterschiedlich ist etwas anderes wenn
ich viele infizierte erwarte als wenn
ich in einer kleinen veranstaltung
machen hier im dorf was ich kenne das
die eine sache ja dass sie also sehen
muss wie groß ist die gefahr dass machen
macht man mit möglich gesundheitsamt
kann das bewerten
die andere sache ist wenn so eine fall
stark läuft dann muss ich als teilnehmer
sozusagen für mich bewerten wie
gefährlich das ist also wirklich sehr
sicher fühle weil ich ein gutes
abwehrsystem habe ich sowieso nie krank
werde in anführungszeichen kann ist
sicher gut hingehen und so ein punkt den
für sehr wichtig halte ist dass ich
selbst entscheide für mich ist mir diese
sache die dort geboten wird so wichtig
dass ich dorthin gehe ich mache mal ein
beispiel generell also wenn ich ein
fußballspiel habe oder ein opernbesuch
vergleiche beim opernbesuch sed husten
etikette gilt ja wo ich weiß wäre
sozusagen neben mir sitzen am ende wird
nur dem sänger applaudiert ist mit
sicherheit das risiko um einiges
geringer als bei
fußballspiele wohl steil war sie nicht
mehr weiß wer neben mir steht und beim
torjubel aus alu machen
wie kann sich dann jetzt jeder einzelne
schützenpaar sachen kennen wir ja schon
händewaschen oder in die armbeuge husten
gibt es noch weitere tipps
ja es gibt sicher einen weiteren sehr
guten tipp wenn wir uns mal überlegen
wie so ein virus übertragen wird
irgendwas 1 was über tröpfchen
übertragen wird wie mussten wir niesen
in die hand und geben mir mal anderen
die hand und dann klebt dieses virus auf
und zur hand und wie geht's weiter es
muss in den rachen also durch packen in
das gesicht wenn man das vermeiden kann
ist das ein fantastisches mittel um die
übertragung zu verhindern allerdings
muss ich sagen sehr schwierig lassen
sich mal beobachten von anderen sie
werden merken sie greifen sich sehr sehr
oft unbewusst ins gesicht weil wenn man
das unterbindet hat man sogar für
infektionserreger die über flächen gehen
guten schutz wie zum beispiel noroviren
wir nämlich von der fläche auf und ich
muss es immerhin warten bringen und wenn
ich unter windows mail sichtweise ist
ein sehr guter
ein guter tipp vielen dank dr wolfgang
kuhn für das gespräch dass iran sehr
gerne noch schneller als das corona
virus selbst hat sich in deutschland die
angst vor dem virus ausgebreitet mit
folgen die jeder in den letzten tagen
zum beispiel in den supermärkten
beobachten konnte teilweise leer gefegt
regale keine nudeln kein reis kein
klopapier so dass an vielen orten aus
dabei gibt es gar keine
versorgungsengpässe
experten mahnen weiterhin zu
besonnenheit warum die angst vor dem
virus trotzdem so ansteckend ist erklärt
dagmar henn
mediziner in schutzkleidung leere regale
abgesagte flüge
es sind bilder wie diese die bei den
berliner psychologen master adli für
einen patientenansturm sorgen corona
angst deswegen muss man im moment
zusammenfassen ist die angst sehr viel
ansteckender als das virus fast leere
regale in den supermärkten verursachen
oft angst zu hungern
vielleicht zu verhungern gehört zu den
urängsten dem entscheid auch wenn der
handel versichert dass ausreichend
lebensmittel vorhanden sind ein ungutes
reaktionsmuster setzt ein
wir fangen an noch intensiver die
nachrichtenportale zu checken nach
steigenden infektionszahlen zu suchen
und so geraten wir in eine richtige
angst spirale die sich hoch dreht und
zwar ganz großen belastung werden kann
die sehr ängstlichen gehen nicht mehr
aus dem haus wer hier unterwegs ist
versucht sich mit der situation
einzurichten ich gehöre nun in ein alter
wo ich nun gefährdet da bin wenn es mich
erwischt
da habe ich beschlossen es wird schon
nichts passieren das macht einen schon
ein bisschen nervös diese panik ist
anstrengend
also das finde ich nicht schön aber
ansonsten hoffe ich dass wir alle gesund
bleiben offensichtlich da eine panik
ihren lauf die nicht gut ist im
wartezimmer von professor atli sammeln
sich diejenigen die die angst nicht mehr
ertragen können aber die angst vor dem
virus ist beherrschbar
mit seinem patienten macht der
psychologe oft berechnungen wie
wahrscheinlich es wirklich ist an corona
lebensgefährlich zu erkranken
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist derzeit
äußerst gering was hilfreich ist ist
sich mit anderen menschen zu
verständigen
mit freunden mit angehörigen
entscheidend ist zu einer ganz
rationalen nüchternen und sachlichen
bewertung der gefahrenlage zu kommen
denn den ängsten vor hunger und
krankheit hat der mensch durchaus etwas
entgegenzusetzen die kräfte der hoffnung
und intelligenz und das war es vom zdf
spezial zum corona virus vielen dank
fürs zu sehen ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen tag
[Musik]